capital police things concerning me
there so they got a 2 billion
dollar just recently uh i think the the
funding yeah the funding was
in the last year or so uh but the point
is is they have a huge war chest
who do they uh who they serve like who
do they report to well they're supposed
to be serving
their their job is to protect members of
congress right uh
so but i mean this is kind of like i
don't know whatever the local police
department here is
and then they say we're going national
and we're expanding our operations
nationwide and we're also going to be
bringing in army equipment so
are they federal yeah it's a federal i'm
actually not sure if they're
technically the federal yeah i think
they are it's a federal police force
that they're expanding they're a federal
police force but they're supposed to be
relegated to the capital
this is
the only issue with the stasi thing is
that you already have the nsa
cia the fbi and about seven seven
seventeen other
this could be the inception of a federal
level
police force intelligence agency beyond
fps or ice that's the concern
we have this quote is from newsweek
reporting on a press release from
capitol police throughout the last six
months the u.s
capitol police has been working around
the clock with our congressional
stakeholders to support our officers
enhance security around the capital
complex and pivot towards
an intelligence-based protective agency
the department said in a news release on
tuesday this was about two weeks ago
yeah so california florida planning
offices around the country
is this uh um you know like like you
were mentioning earlier ian
the mark twain quote history doesn't
repeat it rhymes we look back at uh
the easiest example of authoritarianism
that is overused by millions of people
world war ii germany
the burning of uh you know the reichstag
yeah and then you had the enabling act
and then all of a sudden these sweeping
laws were enacted
opponents of the party were being
rounded up
uh you know look a lot of people want to
believe say things like it can't happen
here
right oh it can even buzzfeed is now
saying that this this whitmer plot
may not even have happened were it not
for the fbi and i think that's a that's
that's
an actually unfair assessment i think
the fair assessment is it would not have
happened right or not for the fbi
we're looking at the capital police in
response to one six
donald we get these news outlets
tweeting donald trump's failed attempt
to overthrow the government like they're
just using the most psychotic language
and now we have the law enforcement
apparatus being constructed
am i supposed to sit here and assume
this is not going to be like every past
authoritarian regime
that is has used a crisis to create an
ideological law enforcement force
or do i see them screaming of the of the
insurrection
and then expanding capital police
nationwide and think to myself
this is a federal police force that is
going to be acting like an
intelligence-based protective agency
how long until they start going after
material support for the
insurrectionists
how long until they start going after
the incitement of the insurrection to
say incitement's a crime right
it's happening now in uh in michigan
whitmer state
you have the attorney general i think
dana nessel is your name
and republicans supported this by the
way but there's now an effort
to investigate people who are
fundraising on what they on what
ag nestle says are false claims about
the election being stolen
in effect this could criminalize
fundraising efforts to secure
an independent election audit in in
michigan
this is a grassroots movement that the
attorney general is talking about
potentially they're saying what they're
basically trying to argue is that if you
fundraise off of it it's fraud
fraud that's right so using the pretext
of fraud
to potentially crack down on legitimate
grassroots effort to secure an election
this is this is this is in line at the
federal with the federal level with jen
sackey saying
that they're working with phone calls
well she didn't say this but working
with
they're working with facebook we got
different reports on politico the biden
admin
and the dnc are working with phone
companies to police
misinformation you know uh peter ducey i
said steve does he accidentally peter
ducey steve is the guy he's dead i think
peter ducey made a really really good
point when he was when he was getting to
that exchange with uh with jen sackey he
said
there is a video of dr fauci from 2020
saying not to wear masks and it's still
on facebook right now
should that be removed and she
immediately
defended dr fauci well dr fauci has said
the science change and we all know
and then he said aren't you scared that
information you would have removed today
could turn out to be correct
yeah that's that that's the principled
position but you see when people want
power
they need to stifle and suppress and
control
so here we go man nestle by the way
right she's the woman who uh when this
woman
whose restaurant was being affected by
the lockdown started to make a lot of
noise about it and and fox was
contacting her about bringing her on to
the carlson show
nestle was the woman who was asking
police if they could quote just have her
picked up before she can go on fox
her emails got leaked to the press and
the dating shows
that after this woman i don't remember
her name right now was making a bunch of
noise but the lockdowns and how it's
affecting business
after that uh nestle sent an email
saying can we just have her picked up
before before she can go on fox
so this woman actually goes on fox goes
and talking carlson's show
and a few days after that she's actually
arrested what was she arrested for
it was it was some minor thing i i'm not
exactly sure
um but but what's crazy is the fact that
this is a thing that just happens now
right that you can get caught
talking about just arresting someone
before they can go talk to the press
and then you actually do it and it was
under under whatever reason right and
then
you it's fine back the blue baby no one
cares got it back to blue
like there's there's an additional
explanation for that i think i'm not
even sure if what they arrested her for
was even related to
like what like the fact that she was
like throwing up a middle finger to the
lockdowns
uh but but the point is regardless they
arrested her as
nestle said they should kind of just
send a message right
it's just bizarre to me well i guess
it's not bizarre because it's 20 21
but still it's just it's a thing that
happens and everyone is just fine with
like this yeah this is this is how we do
things now how funny would it be
if just all the populist right
conservatives just started saying
we we all agree now abolish the police
are the right move we were wrong
like the establishment left would would
flip so quickly
they would be like hail police we love
police
yeah hell police daniel horowitz this is
guy at the blaze
he is not like he's not a populist he's
very much a traditional
unironically principled conservative
again working for the blaze not a
radical outlet
uh and he is he's actually taken this
line defund the police
because he like you he thinks that like
the police are not no longer
actually doing their job they're no
longer actually protecting us from
from crime from violent crime they're in
fact now just kind of acting as the
enforcement arm of the democratic party
it's because
i i think for one i've i've talked to a
lot of cops i've gotten emails from a
lot of cops
the good ones quit right away they were
like i won't do that that's the line
and now what's left are these like you
know a lot of people who are scared to
lose their job
and a lot of cops who aren't actually
doing any work so
to those guys i'm kind of like well you
know yes i guess when you're taking
taxpayer money and doing nothing it's
kind of a problem
but uh it's better than enforcing unjust
laws yeah but you do have a lot of cops
who are just like i don't care
i'll arrest anybody that my boss points
the finger at there was that video
in um i think it was portland i'm not
sure where a bunch of antifa are like
walking towards a guy yelling at him one
guy's got some kind of like stick
i don't think it's a machete i think
it's a bar or something crowbar and
there's a guy walking backwards at the
baseball bat
the cops grab and the guy drops the bat
gets on his knees put his hands up the
cops arrest him and then apologize to
the antifa people
yeah and start saying really nice things
i'm so sorry bro at a certain point
these conservatives need to realize that
the cops are being replaced by black
lives matter
and it's funny because when i've said
before you know we should
defund or abolish the police people are
like tim then national police will come
in
and then the feds will control it all
and i'm like dude
the left already has the police the cops
took a knee
they they dropped on their literally
okay you guys ever watched game of
thrones
bend the knee that was the line it was
like to pledge fealty to the queen
to the khaleesi what what is that
failure of a show at the end yeah but
my point is i don't care what you think
bending the knee means take a knee for
black lives matter yeah they're pledging
fealty
they did now i was still willing to be
like okay we're gonna have an election
and we'll see
this is the kind of thing that's gonna
wake people up and a lot of people did
change their minds trump got a massive
amount of more votes but the democrats
did a lot of things in the lead up to
2020 with with mail and voting changes
that made it that gave them huge
advantages
we saw the article from time magazine
and now the police
are comprised almost entirely in my
opinion of people who either don't care
won't work or actually support antifa
and black lives matter
in which case call their bluff y'all are
going to be fine
you think i'm worried about it i'm not
most conservatives live in rural areas
why is anybody going to be worried about
it i guess if you're living in a city
and you're conservative
but then you're giving tax money to
these people so we got to act like we're
playing the video game of civilization
right now as well as living in the
country just chilling
we're also communicating to hundreds of
thousands of people
creating an an archetype of what it can
be
so i don't want to lose local police i
because the federal police will get
stronger and then you do have the ss and
like
i don't know yeah so we so we really
should empower local police to do the
right thing
but they're they're they're these cops
are too weak well
now generalization you know we don't
know them we really don't know we
see a lot of news articles and make
assumptions so i wrote about
in west virginia the a bunch of
sheriff's departments decided that if if
any
uh really restrictive gun control laws
would get passed the sheriffs
would find these different ways to
basically not enforce them there was one
sheriff i don't remember his name
but he basically said i'm gonna deputize
every single person like and and
that was that was virginia not west
virginia i'm pretty sure yeah okay
virginia
uh i wrote an article about this for
chronicles and it was really funny
because the reporter was like wait
so you're saying that you're just gonna
make everyone a deputy and the [ __ ] guy
was like yeah that's right i'm just
going to give everyone a badge
and then and then that way like the gun
control laws would apply to them so
there i mean there are these good people
on the local level but
but still i think what you're ultimately
get talking about here is this kind of
like attitudinal
attitudinal disposition that
conservatives have
where they still feel a kind of call it
blind
loyalty to institutions that either no
longer exists
or are actually hostile to them yeah and
that
and broadly speaking that institution is
the law enforcement apparatus this is a
very uncomfortable place for
conservatives they're
conservatives are the law and order
people they're the people that
you know that they respect the police uh
they're the ones that follow the rules
they respect hierarchies whether or not
they'll admit it
um and now they're in a position where
they're at the bottom of the food chain
and uh they're being actively persecuted
by the institutions and by the the
people that they think are going to save
i mean
there's a a common thing that
conservatives say is
you know as bad as things get the
military is going to have our back
mark million says yeah mark millie says
that's not the case
and so if you're a conservative who for
your entire life you've been
rah-rah the pentagon you know back the
blue
now like the guns are pointed at you and
i think
i think so so you're right there is uh
there's a discussion that needs to be
had and i think
we're only just beginning to have it
about uh the role of law enforcement
right now where it is hyper-politicized
and you've got police chiefs in huge
cities who are no longer really cops
they're just
bureaucrats and they're not in this for
public safety they're in it for
themselves
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time